[Music]
everybody is talking about the Tupac
hologram at Coachella have you seen this
everywhere well I got the latest
according to sources the Tupac hologram
that performed at Coachella is set to go
on tour it's gonna go on tour yeah I
don't know what the big deal is my
hologram has been hosting this show
since December I'm in Hawaii right now
I'm swimming with dolphins Andy's
claymation oh that explains the
constipation what else is going on
President Obama aguirre up for his
presidential campaign president obama
has created a new series of ads aimed at
latinos yeah the first ad boasts that
just last week my secret service created
jobs for 11 Colombian women this secret
service scandals getting worse yeah yeah
because the secret service prostitution
scandal has gotten worse because
apparently agents were also snorting
cocaine yeah whoever in the agents
defense hotels in Colombia offer cocaine
in the minibar its if you think it's
expensive on the street it it's worth it
to stop on your way to the hotel and get
something yeah
don't touch that coke ya know or the
Snickers bar that's $9,000 now Mitt
Romney's weighing in Mitt Romney said
Secret Service personnel involved in the
scandal should be fired for putting
playtime ahead of the nation yeah so I
think the real story here is that Mitt
Romney describes prostitutes and cocaine
as playtime he's cooler than I thought
oh you mean playtime kids why don't you
run out and play okay dad this is weird
conservatives are now criticizing
President Obama because as a child in
Indonesia Obama sometimes ate dog meat
yeah they seized on that fact in there
yeah but on the plus side Obama's now
pulling very well among cats kitties are
just
I like that yeah yes cuz there are
enemies of dog yeah well see how that
works
no Mega Millions story getting
interesting the married couple in their
60s who won the Mega Millions lottery
said they giggled about it for hours and
bye giggle they mean nervously plotted
to murder each other
[Applause]
a 13 year old boy 13 year old boy from
China will play in an international pro
golf tournament very cool yeah yeah yeah
the boy says he has a unique advantage
since he's the one who made the golf
ball
and done according to a new study that
just came out watching porn may shut
down part of your brain yeah
specifically the part that tells you
you're at work and you should pull up
your pants
[Applause]